president Trump's predicting a red wave
after last night's election results this
comes as the Democrats dream of winning
a race in Ohio's 12th appears to be just
that a dream it's still too close to
call but the president's claiming
victory with Republican candidate Troy
Ball derson leading Trump backed
candidates and other states also having
big nights the president confidently
tweeting about his endorsement hot
streak as long as I campaign and/or
support Senate and House candidates
within reason they will win speaking of
winning the opposite happened for
socialist candidates looking to take
over the Democrat Party their new leader
adding insult to injury with a baffling
new statement I think that politically
disliked upper-middle class is probably
more moderate but that upper middle
class doesn't exist anymore in America
their heyday was in the 90s when like
you know kids had like fur bees and like
parents so you had like soccer moms like
two vans and stuff like Furbies you ban
yeah I counted about seven likes in that
sentence I know that really bothers you
Dana it was like a cute photo on
Facebook so it gets a lot of likes so
what did you think about last night in
general and then also about a good
statement party was an interesting
introduction for that you had there in
that segment the Republicans did okay
but they I don't think they should be
resting that there's gonna be some big
red wave because it's just it's just a
tough environment it always is in the
first midterm for any president and look
at history and there's only one example
and that's kind of an aberration because
of the war I do think that the
interesting thing is how the left-wing
progressives are not winning so more
traditional establishment type moderate
Democrats who have been around the block
a few times they're winning so Bernie
and Alexandria causeway of Cortes they
have an interesting duo they get a lot
of attention they are they they have an
outsized influence in the media but
they're not translating that into wins
on the
I don't know what that necessarily means
going forward I'd also point to
something like in Missouri where voters
voted two to one against a state
legislative law for right to work yeah
and one of the reasons is because the
messaging by the Democrats and the
unions was really good they had one of
these ads that showed okay workers get
paid an average of eight dollars an hour
compared to what this is what CEOs get
and it was effective messaging so some
of the things that we talked about up
here in New York and they were like big
picture over we're not really seeing
what's happening on the ground in some
of these places that's right also
talking about branding Ben Jealous very
upset I believe running for governor in
Maryland and former n-double-a-cp
director he was asked about being
branded a socialist by his Republican
opponent and this is how he responded
[Music]
Gregg you know I think I would vote for
him just for that response because
that's that's it was just so natural I
will say this it to your point okay
Cirrus endorsements when ignored which
leads me to include the only people that
were paying attention to her was us and
we were building her up into something
because she was a socialist and we liked
that we had like a pinata for a while
and and and we were the only people that
were like focusing I love the story I
don't think this is a blue wave I don't
think it's a red wedding it's more like
a purple nurple everybody got a little
as something that with the Democrats
almost won but I love how the Washington
Post's who can look at a victory that
might happen for the Republicans and
still call it a democratic win because
their morale is high and that's all that
matters
my favorite story is the Green Party
spoiler candidate who got 1,100 votes
may have cost the Democrats the election
but the Democrats cannot get mad at him
because he claims he's from outer space
and they are Pro alien really jus
hearing party Democrat he believes that
every American should grow hemp so
what's the bad news about that I know I
was saying that's beautiful for the good
of the country you grow and he can't
read you can't remember his own website
so there might be a correlation I
thought Jesse's intro was you know I
always wear those red the rose-colored
glasses I thought yours were definitely
rose-tinted because there there's
trouble ahead for the Republican Party
unless the president maintains his
hands-on approach he did a great job I
think John James in Michigan is the rock
star of the election last night he's a
West pointer an Apache pilot a combat
veteran a black businessman successful
business grew his business married two
kids I think he really has a tremendous
future I don't know if he could beat the
incumbent debbie Stabenow but I think
he's got a terrific terrific future on
the other hand I think the president's
embrace of Crisco back in Kansas
I mean why Kris Kobach I mean he's a
nice guy he's very articulate I
league-educated but his policies on
immigration are so Neanderthal --is--
that i don't know how he can possibly
win i don't know why the president chose
him probably because of loyalty because
Kobach came in and helped him craft his
draconian immigration policy which i got
to pick on the Neanderthals strict I
think it's strict we have some sound
from Danny Boy
as the president Trump likes to call him
the yo I guess almost made out of
victory in Ohio twelve this is what he
had to say about Nancy Pelosi Candace
will you vote for Nancy Pelosi to be
your Speaker of the House
no I won't and we really need their
leadership because what we've seen in
Washington and I think this was
demonstrated last night that the same
old politics aren't working so they're
running candidates in certain places
candidates that are trying to distance
themselves from Nancy Pelosi and that is
actually a smart move and that's why I
think he had such a successful campaign
look we on the right we had to be very
careful there in Ohio it's been a close
call we don't really know what's gonna
come of it but I will say this the
smartest thing you can do is distance
yourselves from the extremists distance
yourselves from Nancy Pelosi distance
yourselves from Elizabeth Warren
distance yourself from Maxine Waters who
is calling for violence and that's the
only way they are going to be able to
salvage the Democrat Party and look the
thing I was watching last night
obviously was the Democratic Socialist I
was happy to see that that crashed and
it burned and that four of the
candidates at Alexandria Cortes endorsed
nothing happened there because that was
gonna that was a very compelling story
there is that really where we're gonna
go a hundred million a deaths in the
last 100 years due to socialism and
that's what their platform was
essentially built on but it turns out
America good news
most of America understands basic math
and know everything cannot be free I
like I like the platform I have to say I
love $15 an hour minimum wage I think it
I think why not I mean how do you live
with 8 bucks an hour some of these jobs
the math can I actually let me finish
with one else I like that you hate
I think guarantee health care they
should be Medicaid for everybody okay
III think I think the student debt
I mean my goodness and I were too late I
was a movie star for three years I mean
seriously I was the biggest local
newsman in New York three years it took
me to pay off my well I had a hundred
thousand I said our problem loan debt
and guess how I got out of it I worked
my way out of it like everybody else
showed you read the papers you
understand which I didn't at the time
what you're signing and you move on but
listen to this where they save two
dollars an hour means that businesses
are just going to hire less people more
people will be out of work that is the
mathematics of the price of a McDonald's
you got to say the business can't make
the money come out of thin air all right
just just at the two points at per Aldo
raised the minimum wages for people on
the you're not supposed to stay at the
minimum wage it's the it's the entry
level first rung of the ladder so the
idea of raising that of raising that
that that one rung doesn't help anybody
that's just to get more people on the
ladder so you have to keep that that's
why you keep the price level student
debt the reason for that is because we
are giving too many loans out we're
making it easy to go to college and so
now you have all these people and we're
in college let's face it is overrated
it really is it's no it's expensive it's
it's expensive and it's overrated and
now it's it's it's becoming you have all
these kids that are basically enslaved
to to a campuses and it's right it's
nuts but I also just to the coming
election I think we I'm an I'm a
neurotic I plan for the worst I don't
see any really encouraging news for
Republicans I don't out of what happened
last night I just I think you should if
you want to win not the other way around
if you win if you want to win prepare to
lose and that'll make you that'll make
you fight harder it is that part of it
is the funding right so and Congressman
Steve Stivers who's a chairman of the
National Republican Congressional
Committee said okay guys we can't do
this for all of you okay so we put all
this pulled out all the stops I put four
million into that Ohio at least I mean
at least and that doesn't count
independent expenditures not to mention
the travel and time of Pence and
President Trump it you if the
president's going to come and campaign
for you that's a huge investment and you
have to figure out how much time does he
actually have to be going and doing
rallies everywhere for you
you've got to do your work you've got to
figure out a way not to be outspent by
these demagogy give out furbies
how does the president let's just say
things don't go as well as he thinks
they're gonna go
there's no red wave and the Democrats
maybe have one or two vote margin in the
house if he's out there as he says
campaigning six to seven days a week and
he doesn't keep the house
how will he frame that issue how will he
explain what happened well before he
does the explaining the problem with the
Republicans losing the House of
Representatives is what it is that they
will move immediately to try and impeach
the president the United States I really
believe that in my heart even though I
am in many ways a very progressive
person I want him to survive and I hate
the idea that they're gonna
short-circuit his term or attempt to and
and at the very least it's going to be a
gigantic distraction from real problems
lights also gonna be a light Syria also
gonna create massive unrest in America
66 million people knowing that you are
now stealing election because you didn't
like the results of race can I tell you
there's another thing though like it
let's just say that they don't move for
impeachment as Pelosi has said that they
won't there's another road for President
Trump and it's about something he'd be
very good at which is say like well I
did all I could
the media and the lame Republicans who
couldn't get out there and raise enough
money in campaign well they lost but you
know what I can get things done with
these guys I'm a deal maker right you
want to get let's do infrastructure week
let's finally get it done finally there
is another way and Bill Clinton did that
in 1996 94 excuse me kill kill dinner
but he is re-election was actually quite
good if you really if what you really
care about is President Trump getting
reelected in 2020 losing the house is
not the worst thing that could happen to
you all right